الينا من الاردن الخبير الامني والعسكري
عمر الرداد مرحبا واهلا بك استاذ عمر كما
ورد في التقرير التحذيرات من الدول الكبرى
من دول الغربيه بان اي اتفاق جديد للسلاح
بين روسيا وبين كوريا الشماليه يعتبر خرق
للاتفاقيه في مجلس الامن الدولي والى ما
هنالك ولكن هل تابه روسيا او كوريا
الشماليه لاي من الاتفاقيات او القوانين
الدوليه فيما يتعلق بتسليم كوريا الشماليه
لاسلحه نوعيه لروسيا في حربها في اوكرانيا
مساء الخير لك والاخوان المشاهدين لا
اعتقد بالفعل
روسيا لا تابح كثيرا لكنها تتناول هذا
الموضوع يجب ان نعترف انها تتناول بحذر
شديد جدا
وتطرحه باطار ورقه
تثبت انها غير معزوله وان لديها القدره
على اقامه تحالفات اقليميه ودوليه كما هو
الحال مع الصين وكما هو الموقف والخطاب
الاعلامي الروسي تجاه منظمه شنغهاي على
سبيل المثال او بريكس او غيرها من
المنظمات الدوليه لكن المؤكد ان المنفعه
ستكون محدوده حسب ما جاء بتقديركم بالفعل
بحدود تزويد روسيا بدخائر وصواريخ وقذائف
مدفعيه واعتقد هذا يعكس الحجم المشاكل
التسليحيه في روسيا بالمقابل سيطلب
ستطلب
من روسيا ما ينقصها بخصوص تكنولوجيا
الغواصات وتكنولوجيا الفضاء بالاضافه الى
تزويدها بالغذاء بالمنتجات الغذائيه تعاني
حصارا وتعاني مجاعه لكن بالنهايه اعتقد ان
قرار سيكون مرتبطا بشكل مباشر ووثيق بمعنى
ان هي التي تقرر وليس موسكو موسكو ترفع
على قاعده تصريحات او غيره بخصوص الحرب
العالميه الثالثه وتهديد بالنووي وهي
تصريحات تتساوى
بخطاب يتفق مع خطاب القياده في كوريا
الشماليه لكن كوريا الشماليه ستبقى مرتبطه
بحدود كبيره جدا بما تقرره بكين وليس
موسكو
اعتقد انها اليوم حتى ما اشيع عن دخول
كوريا الشماليه في تدريبات عسكريه مشتركه
مع روسيا والصين اعتقد ان
الصين لن تتخذ قرارا متسرعا باشراك
الشماليه بهذه المناورات العسكريه التي
تجري فيما يخص يعني بخص المناورات
العسكريه وتقول انه القرار كوريا الشماليه
فيما يتعلق بتسليح روسيا او بتزويدها
بالاسلحه ومنها ذخيره المدفعيه ايضا مرتبط
بموافقه الصين يعني الكريم اليوم يقول
بانه لا يمكن ان يؤكد اي لقاء مرتقب بين
كيميونغ ان وبين الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ردا على ما اعلنه البيت الابيض انه
اللقاء قريب سيكون بين الطرفين
نعم اعتقد روسيا تدرك هذه الحقيقه وتدرك
ان اوراق وقرارات
موجوده لدى بكين وليس لدى موسكو ولعل
السؤال المطروح اليوم ان العمليه لماذا
تندفع روسيا هذه الاندفاع لولا انها تشعر
بضعف او على الاقل بمشاكل بعد حربها مع
اوكرانيا هذا الانضمام اضافه بين كوريا
الشماليه وموسكو بالاضافه الى انه يتعارض
مع القرارات الدوليه والعقوبات الدوليه
التي وافقت عليها موسكو وهي العضو الدائم
في مجلس الامن ولديه حق النقد الفيتو كيف
لها ان تطالب بعوده امريكا او عوده حرب او
الدول بقيه الدول صاحبه الحريه الدائمه
عن قرارات او ان لا تنتهك قرارات مجلس
الامن
روسيا اعتقد تريد ورقه تفاوض بها الغرب
وتلوح بها اتجاه الغرب وهي ورقه كوريا
الشماليه لكن بالنهايه ستبقى هذه الطبقه
رهينه للمكين
بالدرجه الاولى اذ ان بكين هي الشريان
والرئه الوحيده التي
شكرا لك
اعتقد ان الصين تتخذ سياسات حكيمه وناعمه
ولن تتهور بان تذهب بتصعيد عسكري مع تقييم
وبيونج ضد الغرب بما يستفز الغرب ويؤكد
صوابيه مواقف بان الصين تؤثر بالامن
الاقليمي وامن الجنوب اسيا وبما يفتح
المجال ويجعل المزيد من المبررات لتزويد
تايوان بمزيد من الاسلحه
وكالفلبين واليابان بالاضافه الى كوريا
الجنوبيه نعم استاذ عمر الرداد اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على هذه المداخله وكل هذه التفاصيل
كنت معنا من الاردن